,
SOME WITH MILITARYPPLICATIONS
HAVE INCREASED SIN MOSCOW'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.HERE NOW ISE
SECRETARY OF STATE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
READ TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WE SDROM THE BEGINNG THAT
THIS ADMINISATION WAS SERIOUS
ABOUT CRIPPNG THE WAR EFFORT.
THEY WOULD NOT B FUNDINGT
THROUGH THE BACK DOOR BY
CONTINUINGO DO HUGE BUSINESS
WITH CHI.
>> LAURA, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME ON AND THAT'SXACTLY RIGHT.
NOT ONLY ARE WE FUNDING IT, THEY
STOLE AOT OF INTELLECTUALPROCESS
AND MICROELTRONICS.
THE WOMAN YOU'RE JT SPEAKING
TO TRANSFERRED HERE BACK INHE
UNITED STATES AND W THEY'RE
SELLING IT TO VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
HIS WAR MHINE CAN CONTINUE TO
D
PROBLE BUT THE ADMINISTRATN
HAS NO PLAN OR STRATEGY AND THEY
ARE NOT WILLING TO CONFRONT THE
HA TRUTH THAT'S THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT XI JINPINGND
CHINA CALLS UNLIMITED.
UNLIMITED FRIDS.
UNWILLING TO CONFRONT T
CHALNGE THAT THAT PRESENTS AND
BE SIOUS.
I PROMISE YOU, I AN AMERICAN
COMPANY WATRYING TO BUY A
PIECE OF PROPEY, IT WOUN'T
HAPP AND YET WE ARE NAIVE.
WE ARE SILLY ABO THE WAY WE
THK ABOUT PROTECTING THE
AMERICANEOPLE AND WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHINE
COMMUNISPARTY DIDN'T COME HERE
R AOOD BENIG AND NOBLE
PURPOSE.THEY CAME HERE TO CONDUT
ESPIONAGE.
>> Lau: MR. SECRETARY, TRE
IS BY PARTISANUPPORT AS BETH
SAID.
IF TRE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR STOING THIS.
IF REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL
HAPPEN A WILL TALK TO DR. OZ
IN A MOMENT FROM PENNSYLVANI.
THEY HAV TO STOP THIS.
IT MAY HAVE TO START TALKING
ABOUT IT AND STOP IT.
>> THEY HAVEHE ABILITY TO DO
IT.IFHERE IS WCH WILL BRING
SEMICONDUCTORS BAC FROM CHINA, E
HERE IN THE UNITED STES.
IF THEY CAN PUTANGUAGE IN THE
VERY PIECE OF LEGISLATION THA
WOULD PREVENT THIS TRANCTIONS
TANG PLACE IN NORTH DAKOTA.
TH ARE FREE TO MOVE ABOUT AND
EY DID THE SAME THINWITH A
COMPANY IN KANSAS THAT WAS
MAKING PORK.
THE CHINESE ARE DNG THIS ALL
ACROSS THE COURY.
CONGRESS H THE CAPACITY TO D
THAT.
>> Lau: 1-10 RING, TEN
BEING THE BEST PERFORMCE OFBIDE.
HOW DO YOU RE BIDEN
PERFORMAE IN THE MIDDLE EAST?
>> LRA, I DO MY BEST TO BE
GENEROUS.
IF ONES THE BEST, NINE AND A
HA.
>> Lau: ONE IS THE WORST.
>> THIS IS THE WORST PERFORMANCE
BY A PREDENT IN THE LEASTOR
DECADE AND DECADES.
>> L